President Trump has begun his revenge in
the wake of his impeachment trial
yesterday he asked did the two witnesses
who provided some of the most damaging
testimony against him Gordon Sandlin the
ambassador to the European Union and
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN man who
was the top ukraine expert on the White
House's national security council were
both removed from their post on Friday
this comes two days after the president
was acquitted by the Senate Paula Reid
is at the White House Paula good morning
good morning Michele after ousting these
two key impeachment witnesses the
president appears to be on a campaign of
post acquittal retribution and as he
arrived back here at the White House
last night he ignored questions about
whether these firings are meant to send
a message to anyone who testifies
against him was there a quid pro quo the
answer is yes
late Friday Gordon Sam Lindh revealed he
has been recalled from his post as a US
ambassador to the EU nearly three months
after he testified that top
administration officials knew about an
alleged campaign to pressure Ukraine to
investigate the Biden's
everyone was in the loop in a statement
Sandlin said he was advised the
president intended to remove him
effective immediately the announcement
came just hours after Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander VIN men who also testified
against the president in the impeachment
hearings was escorted from his desk at
the White House is a message to testify
against you VIN Minh a Purple Heart
recipient and Iraq war veteran was
assigned to the White House's National
Security Council and wasn't due to leave
until July in November he testified
about listening in on a call where mr.
Trump asked the president of Ukraine to
investigate former Vice President Joe
Biden and his son it was improper for
the president to request an to demand an
investigation into a political opponent
opponent in a statement vimi's lawyer
said the truth has cost VIN Minh his job
his career and his privacy during his
testimony
men had a message for his father do not
worry I will be fine for telling the
truth
the White House is said four months that
it wanted to downsize the NSC and denied
VIN men would be retaliated against but
late Friday the president's son Donald
Trump jr. tweeted thanking chairman Adam
Schiff who led the impeachment inquiry
for helping unearthed quote who all
needed to be fired VIN Minh will now go
back to the Pentagon for reassignment
defense secretary Mark Esper said he
will be welcomed we protect all of our
persons service members from from
retribution or anything anything like
that at last night's debate former Vice
President Joe Biden led a standing
ovation for VIN Minh and even suggested
he should receive a medal meanwhile VIN
mins brother yevgeniy who worked at the
National Security Council as a lawyer he
too is escorted off the premises
yesterday and he too will now return to
work at the Pentagon Geoff Paula thank
you very much